[Music]
foreign
would have been the mission wall that
surrounded the Alamo and that's the wall
that the Mexican troops hit I'm right in
the battlefield of why Texas is Texas
Vince Cantu runs Moses roses a San
Antonio Texas bar that's on the site the
famous 1836 battle memorialized on the
big screen many times by the likes of
John Wayne and Billy Bob Thornton he
opened Moses roses in 2010 after it had
sat vacant for many years
my family's been here for four
generations running taverns downtown San
Antonio I'm proud of my family my great
grandfather had a Tavern four blocks
that way my grandmother had a restaurant
my grandfather had a restaurant less
than a quarter mile that way I feel like
I am on the shoulders of giants I like
what I do and I like where I do it I
never really thought about it happening
to me until it happened to me I've been
living under the threat of MN domain for
six years
the Alamo trust a non-profit that man
that man wants to expand
Moses roses currently stands Cantu says
that in 2016 the group made its first
offer of a million dollars signed by
then land commissioner George P bush
which would have barely covered his
outstanding loans four years later they
upped it to 2 million
and I've told them no about times mostly
because you know I'm 60 years old and it
puts me out of a job come back in 10
years and see what it's worth and maybe
maybe that's the way I want to do it
because I'm not going to I'm not gonna
look at 10-year money at three percent a
year when it's been appreciating it like
18 a year
the outset the 400 million dollar Museum
Expansion Project
ing fell through this the state of Texas
stepped in to cover the cost the state
made two more offers which Cantu
rejected he said he'd sell for 15
million so State officials who declined
to participate in this story countered
by threatening to take his property by
force using eminent domain Cantu would
receive a so-called fair market price
based on an independent Appraiser's
estimate of the property's current value
the appraisal came in at 2.1 million or
roughly 2.8 million in 10 years in
December the Alamo trust offered 3.5
million which can too quickly declined
they keep alleging that you're not
negotiating in good faith what do you
say to that all lies they've never
called me so we never really had a
negotiation they would send me an email
with it with an offer I would send them
an email back saying No thank you and
some other words they've wanted to
negotiate with me over my property but
they wanted a loaded gun to do it
they've wanted the threat of imminent
domain hanging over my head for me to
take their number instead of them taking
my number
and in running a business when you're
under the threat of imminent domain is
really really hard I mean you know
because you're as a business person
you're looking out
today tomorrow
a month from now but you're also looking
out five and ten years out to see what
you need you need a new AC system you
need uh you need to remodel a place you
need to put some money into it some
other way
and not knowing whether the government
was going to come in and take it at any
at any moment
um really kind of defeated the whole Joy
I had about thinking about the future of
this place and developing 10-year
strategies
a pissed off Cantu started tacking on an
extra million dollar fee to his offer
each year that the government threatened
him with imminent domain and earlier
this year George P bush who's the son of
Jeb and the nephew of George W called
cantu's refusal to sell at the state's
price dishonorable
I told my wife that if I saw him I would
challenge him to a duel in front of the
Alamo I would use uh would you squirt
guns not real guns because I don't want
to kill anybody I don't want to get
killed but uh you know I mean just to
just to avenge my honor Bush didn't
respond to recent's requests for comment
proponents of the alamo's plan would
argue that this is necessary it's
necessary that they take these buildings
that they seize them in order to expand
the The Visitor Center the new theater
that they're building what do you say to
those people who are supporters of the
Alamo really expanding their footprint
in the city well those people that say
that that support that are the ones that
read in the paper that I would not come
to the table but the truth is is that
I've told the museum people for six
years that I would come to the table
that I've been waiting for six years for
my phone to ring for for them to sit
down and have an honest negotiation with
me so I've never been in the way of what
they wanted to do so I would say how
could I be in the way of something when
I've told them I would sell to them from
day one they just never have wanted to
meet me even close to my price and
that's the government saying we don't
have to because we can Emma domain you
instead
Cantu says that when he started Moses
roses it was in a dilapidated part of
town he and his family are being denied
the opportunity to reap the rewards of
more than a decade of sacrifice
this part of downtown San Antonio was
not a place anybody really came it was a
bunch of homeless people here my idea
was to open up a bar and grill and have
live music but most of the people that
played for me at first were just
homeless guys with guitars I mean that's
really kind of what we had over here
really and then after a while it just
kind of started clicking downtown
started opening up a little bit and this
part of downtown started getting a
little bit more gentrified and a little
bit better
January to authorize the use
the use domain which would allow the
city to condemn and acquire the property
to hand to the Alamo trust if Cantu
doesn't take their state-backed offer
after our interview Cantu met with the
trust's attorneys he says they offered
him 2.4 million more than a million
dollars less than what they'd offered
him before the city started the eminent
domain process it was just a bad faith
negotiation that they you know
said they had to have before they would
start imminent domain Cantu has vowed to
keep fighting
protection is small government and
um and fiercely independent it's
stupidly ironic completely on Texan
[Music]